all right let's go next to our caller
from the seven one three area code who's
calling today from seven one three
yeah I'm mr. pachtman this is Cody
calling from Southeast Texas
Cody describe to me how far from the
speaker phone you are well I've had him
on my headset but let me get rid of that
real quick no problem just writing
Bluetooth here in the notes thank you
sure oh my goodness it's so much better
yes son again my apologies mr. back when
I really apologize man you sound like
you're on an ER e20 radio microphone all
of a sudden okay I don't know what that
is but that's pretty good it's very very
good
okay yeah I have a couple of questions
for you I understand they give a lot of
callers okay so some hold on a second
something just you know you can't hear
me anymore but that's you know from a
trial law kind of perspective question
hello hello what benefit any would you
see them oh my I don't know what is the
witness chair and hey uh Cody can you
still hear me buddy
Cody can you hear me all right we're
gonna let him go